hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to weekly update number three so
I thought I'd I thought to mix it up
with the weekly updates i'm not in time
i'm not out of town and do you guys
since here i'm here in my office and
here in my room and and yeah so i
thought that I'd mix it up right every
week I thought that I use a different
microphone just just for fun really so
today our special guest is this is shure
sm58 now it's very popular microphone
it's like a dynamic microphones usually
used for like singing and live
performances but you know it's fine for
recording a lot of actual a lot of
actual like artists used it for
recording voice in studios as well
because I'm they really like the sound
of this thing and also it's really
strong just does not break so that's the
that is the shure sm58 lim know what you
think of the sound quality and ya know
just a little like a fun bonus type
thing but yeah this is weekly update
number three get excited alright so
first of all thank you for eight point
seven thousand subscribers thank number
two arm number two I wanted to mention
that I actually began developing the
channel engine further so I sort of
resumed those live streams where I am
basically stream myself developing the
channel engine so for those of you don't
know I'm going to talk a bit about the
channel engine so what is the cherno
engine the chernobyl engine is sort of
like a framework that I really wanted to
build that um it's an it's a gay man
shits a 2-d game engine right at least
the first version of the channel
engineers it's a 2-d game engine that um
that's written purely in Java so no
opengl nothing just purely Java I might
actually make an opengl version but the
way that I see it like unless I'm making
something 3d I don't really need the use
I don't really need the help of OpenGL
honestly like I guess it would help in
Fault in slower computers and would give
you it would definitely improve your
performance but I just don't see a
necessary in creating small games I
think that I'm pure job was fun fine for
that and also it's actually really fun
to do that but yeah so sure no engine
the reason I wanted to make the channel
engine is because I wanted to provide
you guys with like some sort of some
sort of framework really to on to
basically aid you I guess in making
games but not know
only that but I also had this idea along
a long time ago just to make um on that
long ago but I I had this idea to
actually make um just small like videos
the one relatedness in like a series or
anything no it's not like a show but
just one of videos where I would just
demonstrate one like thing or one
technique or one tip that I want to give
to give to you guys that I'm really help
you out in in game development and the
thing is like I didn't really want to
start from scratch John because like if
I want to show you one tip if I feel
like I need a ride like a thousand lines
of code to actually get the game to a
point where i can actually demonstrate
this tip your honor man but like if I've
already got the framework I could be
like alright guys here's the challenge
and download it ah you know unzip it put
into project utilize it and then I'll
show this technique by using twenty
lines of code which is what the
technique actually is so in other words
I won't have to start from scratch I
could just make you guys a video and
yeah and you guys would know exactly
what Anna and it would focus exactly on
the thing that I wanted to teach you
guys instead of having to start from
scratch every time I wanted a new tip so
that's sort of whether you did the idea
originated from and also it'd be pretty
sick like making a game engine the you
guys could use that would really help
you out as well and it would really be
like a higher level place to start
wouldn't be wouldn't be really low level
so that that's good that's good so yeah
that is the true engine second third
this is the third thing isn't it third
thing I wanted to say was in regards to
the actual live streams for the channel
engine so I've sort of been streaming I
want to stream them once a week right
instead of an episode of game
programming I want to have a live stream
that day that goes maybe you know once
two hours somewhere around that and and
so I did one on Friday last Friday so
two days ago Friday night so friday
night australia's entail that time which
was pretty cool videos on demand i'll
talk a bit about live streams in a
minute but um
I did I did that and that was that was
awesome but yeah I'll do that probably
friday nights a lot of people ask me to
move it to saturday night but um I don't
know I might actually do that because I
would be coming convenient because then
that that would mean the game
programming episodes would be five times
a week like monday to friday so from
monday to friday nights australia's in
daylight time a new episode of game
program would come out and then saturday
would be live show no engine live stream
and sunday would be um sunday would be
what what's on sunday what's on sunday
weekly update is on sunday that's what's
on sunday this would be on sunday so I'm
yeah that's what I mama I don't know I
might do that you know I have a tendency
do you actually go out and do stuff with
friends of mine so that's why I guess
that's not his pants if I go like
somebody goes saturday night or Friday
night like one of them I might just
reschedule the live stream to be you
know the one that I'm not out for so
yeah as far as live streams work a lot
of people very concerned about live
streams first of all germany germany
germany germany germany germany germany
germany i did not know so many people
watch my videos from germany but they do
because I constantly get tweets every
time I try and live stream when I can
watch live stream in Germany now there
is there you can watch larger in Germany
and to you don't really need to watch
the livestream share in Germany that's
actually kind of selling man but what I
mean is every time I finished every time
I have a live stream if it is on youtube
which anything related to the journal
project channel will be on YouTube I
never stream on Twitch if I'm doing game
development stuff alright if there is
anything to do with this channel with
the cherno project that stuff will be
streamed on youtube.com forward slash
the show no project ok secondly when i
finish streaming every time I stream on
youtube every time I finish streaming it
takes about depending on the length of
the live stream it takes a while to
process the video and then it
automatically gets uploaded to YouTube
where you guys can watch it ok and the
way you can tell us a live stream by the
way is instead of like you know how it
says when like the video will upload it
like it says like published on on an
hour I was there today like 13th of
January
12 you know how says like published on
13th of January 2012 if it's a live
stream it'll actually say streamed live
on 13th of january two thousand twelve
so that way thousand thirteen sorry so
that way you know that it's actually
it's a live stream it's not on such as
the video uploaded so yeah so don't
worry you can actually watch my
livestreams like when they're not live
they'll be available video on demand
alright sick so people from Germany if
you can't watch my livestream is because
your government doesn't let you then you
can watch them when they're not live now
if you really do want to watch them when
they're live there is something called
prox tube p 0 p r or x tube prox tube
that will will actually allow you to
plug in for google chrome you can you
can just grab that and you can you can
actually watch live streams in germany
if you do that ok simple as that prox
tube install install that plug-in for
google chrome might be four firefighters
as well i'm not sure on use firefox but
um if you blow if you use that plugin
for google chrome then every time you
come to something that's locked in your
country it actually unlock it i even
used it for some things because there
are some some videos on youtube that are
actually blocked in australia so yeah I
can just I use proc stripping that
unblocks adil it also unblocked live
streams so yeah that's awesome but other
than that that's pretty much all i have
to say about live streams all right so
the fourth thing is Daisy I've been
getting into Daisy and I love it I've
actually been told about Daisy like a
like everyone's just been talking to me
about Daisy and it's like I think I
doesn't again the runaround Allah like
kind of like konai late league of
legends really with League of Legends a
lot of my friends would like played it a
lot and I just didn't take go to take
notice of it and then I got into it and
I really really enjoyed it and I just
had an awesome time so it's like kind of
the thing I actually I just haven't
played League of Legends like half a
year honestly um I don't know why I just
kind of just I went to Germany for a
while and I couldn't really play it
there and then when I came back when I
came back to Australia I just didn't
really want to play it again they've
been like 10 new champions and stuff
playing but anyway Daisy so I guess kind
of same same thing with Daisy I really
am I started watching frankieonpc
1080p playing um Daisy and he's just
such a nice guy by the way frankieonpc
in 1080p if you like gaming videos and
haven't checked him out and you like PC
gaming check him out his is just oh I
love that guy man he's awesome so yeah
check him out but um I what I was
started watching his daily videos and
then I'm like you know what I'm gonna
grab Daisy so I you know I bought
armored to actually a bar amá to while a
while before i bought up what it's
actually kind of interesting sorry i
bought armature like three weeks before
i bought before I'm downloaded days
eight days it's very obviously but I
bought armor two combined operations
because it was like on a steam sale it
was like half price something got the
whole thing like fifteen dollars it's
like 30 if you want to buy buy them now
but I'm yeah I go for like 15 bucks and
then I you know like a few weeks later
I'm like I'm only had Daisy so i
downloaded Daisy got that recently and
yeah and it's it's really it's really
cool so if you guys haven't checked out
Daisy it's a good way to it'sit's good
thing to check out it's basically like a
survival game it's a really realistic
survival game in a zombie apocalypse and
there are other players who will
potentially kill you or you can kill
them but the coolest thing you can do is
tell them to put their hands up drop
their weapon and take them hostage all
work together with them innocence it's
not like things you do here um but yeah
if there's any people out there who play
dayz especially if you're in Australia
and do you want to like form like a
group with me and just we could just
chill out survive basically and dominate
the servers then go ahead add me on
skype add me on the channel project so
just the thing will be in the
description but it's literally the turn
of project that's like my fan skype so
on but if you really if you wanna play
dayz with me and you're in Australia
then what when you're sending the
contact request just tell me that I'm
from Australia I want to play dayz with
you that's it and then I'll know if
anyone else wants to add me on skype i
guess you can but just say hi or
something don't tell me that you're from
Australia you want Daisy because that
don't don't hi basically you just want
to be on my if you just want to
me on skype and you can do that I guess
it's not really a big deal it's my fan
skype so i guess that's what it's for
right but um that's the journal project
so yeah obviously some of you guys
around maybe we can place him Daisy
because it's awesome and none of my
friends seem to have computers that can
run like I felt like to literally got
two people two friends true close
friends who are there even close friends
that's mean isn't it saying that's mean
it's like Facebook have facebook has
like a close friends list and I'm like
do it like if I had someone to that
that's gonna be really kind of a dick
move do you think like wow it's like no
you're still my friend but I don't like
you as much as this guy like what anyway
point is to my friends told my close
friends they've got good computers and
they can run Daisy but everyone else
like usually they're only there were
like laptops so armature requires a big
computer a big mean machine anyway
that's pretty much going to wrap up this
weekly update hope you enjoyed it
minecraft server would have a little
trouble with that thing I recently
exceeded my disk quota so I gone to
their 22 multiplies twenty four seven
support live chat support first time I
try to get on it Friday night was
offline that twenty four seven support
was offline but Saturday luckily they
were online got onto them I asked him
you know this error message case of them
are popping up every time I saw my
server I try to stop myself because it
doesn't just doesn't start instead of
tells me that I've exceeded my desk
quarter and like a big error message and
is like no problem I'll up your disk
quota but just tell just make sure you
need to control the size IAM of your
safe of your world basically don't yeah
so basically he's a lot of asking you
guys to not go out too far because you
go out too far it's not going to work
but other than that the FTB just keeps
crashing that's nothing to do with me
nothing to do with multi-play it's to do
with the FTB card so i don't even know
how guys like if this heat if this keeps
happening until they stabilize it like
I'm even considering the diff is really
keeps happening and the servers like
offline for as long as it is on
we won't take a vote and actually he's
got a vanilla minecraft honestly because
um I don't know maybe you guys would
like vanilla minecraft server instead of
FTB Jana both could unfortunately does
cost money although a few of you guys
have been generous enough to donate I
didn't even announce that um people can
donate because I don't really want to
seem like I'm taking money from me but
um if you guys want a vanilla minecraft
server instead of FTB let me know and
maybe it'll be a top government
conveniently someone asked me to talk
about something last week thing also in
to do without lwjgl that was like the
top comment I can't run out of time but
as far as lwjgl on this channel goes
there's a guy called decoding universe
check him out I've I'm yeah he's pretty
cool I have talked to him on skype and
stuff so we do kind of know each other
we acknowledge each other's existence um
but ya know he's definitely he's really
cool check out he hasn't doesn't really
post that often though not as often as
me I guess that's probably has something
to do with you know his life being busy
my life is really busy actually but I
finished school so hey but anyway the
point is check him out he makes it makes
him pretty damn good videos but also um
also as far as I live lwjgl on this on
this channel goes I don't know like if
you I don't know maybe in the future
like because I know I really don't want
to balance two series at once what I'm
trying to do that was 3d game
programming but um other than that like
I don't know we'll see we'll see we'll
see I'm actually yeah that's actually no
I gather but um anyway that's going to
wrap up this weekly update weekly update
number three next time we'll um we'll
talk about some other stuff so next time
maybe you guys can leave the topic for
me to talk about next time and I'll talk
about that next time but yeah if you
enjoyed this video please hit the like
button and favorite button and the
subscribe button if you haven't already
I'm sorry I'm just trying to think of
like another button you guys can click
to help me out but you know anyway
that's it so I'm going to go back to
playing dayz and i'll see you guys later